in this video i'm gonna explain the
single equation that helped me turn 1036
dollars into over 120 million dollars in
sales and right now um our portfolio
company is about 85 million a year i
have nothing to sell you
so this concept has been the central
concept up to how we've grown each of
our portfolio companies with 100 equity
without taking on outside capital or
investors right and so the key here is
if you don't have a lot of money you
have to think different and play the
game differently
most people when they try and play the
game when they when they get the
investors from outside or they have some
sort of seed capital of their own they
think i'm going to have to take two or
three years before my business uh is
break even or positive and that is
definitely a belief that you can have
but not necessarily one that you have to
have right and so i prefer to you know
change the variables the game that we're
playing uh to try and figure out a way
to make money all the time right because
it's like well if i could make money the
whole time then that would make this
definitely more fun and a lot less
stressful and so the equation that i'm
going to outline for you is what i call
client finest acquisition this is how we
grew our first uh lice you know shoot i
grew i went from zero to six locations
at my brick and mortar chain uh in three
years as a 26 year old and i was able to
open up each of those locations at full
capacity except for the first one
obviously but each of the ones after
that once i learned how to do this uh on
day one so that's not normally common so
we're gonna open up each facility at
complete completely full capacity and
then i did this at 33 other locations
over the next few years after that we
transitioned to our licensing business
and we used the exact same model that
i'm about to show you uh to go from zero
to two and a half million dollars a
month within i think it was like 12 or
14 months and then and that's per month
not per year so went from zero to 28
million top line right and then uh 12
months after that we're at 4.4 million a
month the second business that added
that up went from zero to 1.7 million a
month in four months all right the third
business we started our software
business went from zero to also 1.7
ironically within six months all right
and so this equation matters profit
matters if you want to be in a
capitalist society because it's the only
way that you're gonna be able to weather
the storms all right so this is the
writer downer this is an equation but
it's a process all right
client financed acquisition what this
means in plain terms is get your
customers
to pay for all of your marketing and
your acquisition costs and so what that
means is if you can plug into the
universe's money not your own money but
you plug into the money of the universe
you can pretty much cash flow anything
you need because you can make more money
getting someone to enter your world than
it costs you to get them there and if
that is your case and you still have all
the lifetime value that you're going to
collect but if you can do that in the
first 30 days and you can and you can
pay the cost of fulfillment and still
have money left over then you have what
is called a negative acquisition cost
right it means that you make money
getting customers all right so this is
the actual equation you know the number
two but then there's three things in
here that you may or may not understand
and so i'm going to break down each of
them let's call this number one let's
call this number two let's call this
number three so if i were to read this
in plain english it would say 30-day
cash oopsies
i usually write this the other way
30-day cash must be greater than
two times the cost of acquiring customer
and the cost of fulfilling that customer
okay so what this means is
cost of acquisition all right so let's
say it cost me a hundred bucks to
require a customer and that includes my
marketing team that includes
my sales guys and their commissions that
includes the advertising or whatever
method i did to acquire the lead okay so
let's say all luna cost me 100 bucks i'm
just using simple math here let's say
that for me to
fulfill this thing whatever the thing is
let's say it cost me another hundred
bucks all right so that's 200 that's
going to cost me
to fulfill and sell
this thing these are my costs right
and so the idea is i have to have two
times the sum of this all right remember
this is in our little parentheses which
means this is 400
that is what i must make right that has
to be less than what i make in 30 day
cash which is a term that i use that
i've never really heard anywhere else
i'm sure there's a fancier word for it
but i call it 30-day cash which is the
amount of money that i can collect
in net free cash flow to my business
within the first 30 days of a custer
customer entering our world now we may
have upsells and down sales and
continuity and future things that we're
going to sell
but none of that matters to the small
business owner who doesn't have cash and
so the reason it's 30 days
is because that's the amount of time
that you can get interest refinancing
all right so if you have a credit card
people will extend your money for 30
days interest free that means if you
paid off in the first 30 days you can
you can pretty much take unlimited money
all right for the most part now you pay
your stuff off you get bigger limits
whatever but the point is and this is
literally how i started my second
business
is that i would use my cards and put the
money on the card to acquire the
customer so on my card there'd be two
hundred dollars
because that's what's going to cost me
to fulfill and acquire but i would have
made
400
on that
and the reason it has to be greater than
this is because i have net right because
we have to take out the 200 that we lost
here did you right minus 200 so i have
200 left over
what a coincidence that's the exact
amount that it's going to cost me to get
another customer and fulfill that
customer which means that i'm gonna get
you guessed it another four hundred
dollars from this customer
and we play the game again which means
that you have unlimited power to acquire
new customers
which means you get unlimited money
which is why if you if you play the game
this way and you choose to think about
acquisition in this manner you can grow
your companies without capital
constraint now it doesn't mean that
there won't be constraints there will be
you have operational constraints of
hiring constraints of other things but
if you play the game this way getting
new customers and making sales will
never be the thing that is limiting your
company it will be only you and this is
what we've done over and over and over
again is design a process in every
business that we can figure out where
the amount of dollars that we make in
the first 30 days is greater than two
times the cost to acquire plus the cost
of fulfill and that works in any
business in the world all right and now
ideally i don't want to be just twice it
just has to be more than that if i can
make this you know 10 times right
then it's even better all of those uh
make it just even easier because then
i'm getting multiple customers and i
still have cash flow to go invest in
other things but this is the minimum
requirement
for cfa or what we call client
financed
acquisition and so right now if you
don't have money or you don't have
capital and you think it takes money to
make money
you just keep believing that beautiful
lie
and let everyone else go win while you
keep complaining all right so keeping
awesome mosey nation i know you're not
that type of person um and so we can
beat all those people who have those
limited beliefs um but i had 1036
dollars in my bank account
five years ago all right right now the
portfolio we do does 85 million dollars
a year i took no outside money to do
that which means if you can learn how to
play and multiply and multiply and
multiply and not use your own money
because i'm using my customers money to
finance all of the growth in this
business if you enjoyed this if this if
you found value in this i make these
videos i have nothing to sell you
click subscribe i'll see you next video
i know this is a little bit more
tactical
i'll talk about more managing people and
scaling the company side but this is the
this is the stuff right this is the
stuff this is the these are the things
that actually grow the business all
right so anyways love you all keeping
awesome as a nation i'll see you guys
next vid bye